ja wir kommen zur letzten sitzung dieses
semesters im seminar gut und böse heute
geht es um einen rückblick und um eine
abschlussdiskussion wir haben sehr viele
positionen behandelt im rahmen dieses
seminares gut und böse und ich möchte
jetzt einen kurz durchlauf geben immer
wieder werde ich dann auch oben rechts
verweisen auf die jeweiligen
aufzeichnung dieser sitzung beginne mal
mit dem anfang wir hatten uns die frage
gestellt ob es überhaupt eine
philosophie des bösen geben kann was sie
eigentlich ist es überhaupt möglich und
sinnvoll über das böse zu philosophieren
es hängt natürlich ganz entschieden
davon ab was wir unter den bösen
verstehen es gibt auffassung die sagen
dass das böse nichts ist dass das böse
eine bloße privaten ein mariam sein ist
wenn wir es so verstehen dann wird es
schwierig über das defizitäre zu
philosophieren das was ich im ziel
ist das böse wieder irrtum und das nicht
sein phänomen das sich dem
philosophischen zu können zieht dann
wird schwierig darüber zu philosophieren
auch könnte man sagen dass wir immer
schon dazu neigen am guten moralisch
guten und an der wahrheit orientiertes
sein
und dabei die schattenseiten nino der
philosophie sind auch des lebens aus dem
blick zu verlieren das böse wäre ja
gerade eine schattenseite
meine these ist wir können über das böse
philosophie müssen aber diese täuschung
die schattenseite selbst ausdrücklich
einbeziehen zu bösen gehört ist wie ich
finde dass es schein und schatten und
dunkelheit erzeugt auch wenn es selbst
nicht unbedingt dunkel ist aber es
erzeugt dunkelheit auf irritation lügen
und so weiter ja wie ist das verhältnis
von gut und böse zu bestimmen
ja es ist sehr komplex wir können das
auf ganz verschiedene weise stehen wir
können es als das kontradiktorische
gegenteil des guten verstehen sich die
kontraktion these also das gut ist das
nicht böse dass nicht böse ist das gut
so könnte man es verstehen
kontakt sonst hieße das böse könnte als
prima zion beraubung des guten verstand
werden die privaten these all das
böseste ein mangel an guten ein mangel
an sein
diese these vertritt protein und thomas
von aquin gesehen es gleich noch das
böse kann als perversion das heißt als
wesentliche umkehrung und verklärung des
guten verstanden werden also will
endlich dass es die perversion steens
das beginnt dann ungefähr mit augustinus
und head sieht sich fort bis kant und
nach kant fichte sogar das sind so diese
möglichen positionen ich will damit
nicht sagen dass es alle sind aber es
sind schon die wichtigsten hier kann man
jetzt ein paar einwendet bringen gegen
die erste auffassung die kontrakt
aktions these könnte man sagen dass er
sie nicht in plan a bloßen in logischen
beziehung der kollektion bestehen gute
böse sind dass man es noch näher
bestimmen kann das böse ist nicht nur
das nicht gut gesonnen war es
gibt sich den anschein dass guten und da
sieht man diese logische konzeptions
these die greift das phänomen ich
richtig die begreift dass nicht die wird
diesen komplexen verhältnis vermuten
würde nicht gericht eine lose
konditions- auffassung
der zwei spricht also die auffassung
dass
das böse alle privaten
des guten ist spricht dass damit eine
asymmetrie also ein gegensatz
berücksichtigt wird zwischen google böse
dagegen spricht dass hierbei die
realität ist dass die tiere sich
faktisch dienst wir begebene bösen
täglich und seine zurechenbarkeit aus
freiheit zu wenig berücksichtigt wir
sind ja selbst verantwortlich für das
fest wenn es nur ein effekt ist dann
muss man sich fragen sieht überhaupt
wird das böse dafür verantwortlich und
drittens
das war die koalition ali these die
perversion these dafür spricht dass das
gut und böse
unsere freiheit entstand unsere
individuelle freiheit ein problem ist
jedoch dass wenige dass wir dadurch
nicht genau erklären können warum wir
uns für das böse entscheiden sollten
wenn wir uns noch genau so gut aus
freiheit für das gute entscheiden können
warum sollten überhaupt das böse tun da
ist auch nicht ganz klar aus dieser
perversion these das möchte die nutzer
bedingen geben vorab und jetzt haben wir
mögliche kandidaten des gut und böse
noch behandelt im seminar also
kollektive personen
staatengemeinschaften kollektivität
these denken sie an den
nationalsozialismus dieser staat könnte
in seiner gesamtheit als böse bezeichnet
werden aber auch individuelle person
oder menschen personalität these
handlungen böse handlung verbrechen
aktivitäts diese der wille erinnern sich
an kant gut oder böse ist nun guter oder
böser wille sie volition ali these der
name darüber diskutiert dass es
deterministische umstände sein könnten
also ich bin so geprägt worden meine
umstände meine eltern ein soziales
umfeld hat mich böse gemacht dass wir
die determinismus zeese haben sie sehen
es gibt hier ganz verschiedene
auffassungen mein favorit ist der wille
und die handlung aber
auch
kollektiv personen staatengemeinschaften
sind ein spannender kandidat
ja jetzt möchte ich einen überblick über
die behandelten position geben wir
hatten es erst mal platin und platon zu
tun das sei das guten der mangel des
bösen dann mit augustinus er will ins
zentrum gestellt thomas verlag wien da
wurde die technologie also die
zielrichtung des guten behandelt und der
mangel des bösen leibnitz das böse in
der besten aller möglichen welten
kant wir hatten uns mit dem guten und
dem bösen befasst fichte die trägheit
des bösen regelt die logik des guten und
bösen aller und banalität des bösen für
die bafu die natur des guten der präfekt
des bösen und zum schluss der letzten
sitzung susan nehmen und bettina
stangneth über aktuelle theorien des
bösen ich möchte jetzt ganz kurz nach
rückblick geben auf alle die genannte
position und die wesentlichen kappe
punkte noch mal kurz erklärt also dann
bekomme platon
leitung hat dieses bekannte
höhlengleichnis entwickelt dass wir
aufsteigen müssen aus der schattenbild
uns zur idee des guten erheben müssen
das gebäude wird hier als idee gefasst
als science und erkenntnis grund der
welt der wahrheit
das gute ist über allem sein denn
jenseits des seins weil die dinge in der
welt erst durch das gute die idee des
guten überhaupt ihre realität und
erkennbarkeit erhalten das kann man sich
hier fragen ja wo ist dann das böse
angesiedelt gibt es noch platt und eine
idee des bösen damit gesagt das geht
wohl nicht wo es dann das böse zu suchen
wo wir in dieser schatten wird ja in
diesem bereich wo wir getäuscht werden
und diese schalten wir die sache macht
platon eher weniger seid also das böse
ist nicht ein idee sondern es ist diese
sphäre der realität die uns täuscht und
die durch ihre täuschung struktur
weniger real ist als das gute
platte pro team der neue platonischer
blatt unentschieden an
entwickelt das ganze aber noch weiter er
sagt das böse ist eine privat ion eines
tieres ist ein mangel an guten und das
böse besteht in den körper den
körperlichen gehen warum weil die
körperliche dinge dem wandel unterliegen
dem entstehen und vergehen und gut ist
nach blut ihn nur dasjenige was ewig ist
was unveränderliches also die idee zum
beispiel das böse hingegen ist das
entstehen und vergehen und unsere körper
entstehen und vergehen das ist die
präventions- theorie von putin da mache
ich dann auch oben rechts den link rein
dann hatten wir es mit augustinus zu tun
augustinus in eine ganz spannende
position augustinus hat einen
christlichen hintergrund
er ist theologe und philosoph er sagt
gut ist allein der gute willen böses der
böse wille das böse besteht im gebrauch
unseres willens und er geht so weit dass
er sagt wir können sogar das böse um des
bösen willen tun hier darf ich noch mal
dran erinnern an den bildern diebstahl
augustinus sagte hat in seiner jugend
eine birne gestohlen nur um sie zu
stehlen nicht weil das essen wollte weil
es gut geschmeckt hatte sondern weil er
einfach das gebot du sollst nicht
stehlen verletzten wollte aus freiheit
auch da mache ich dann oben rechts den
kran das könnte man als eine perversion
theorie bezeichnen eine sehr radikale
theorie andere dinge wie kant fichte
haben danach bestritten dass wir das
bewegung des bösen willen tun können
thomas von aquin
ein mittelalterlicher verlosung der hat
wieder eine ja der prothetischen theorie
ähnliche auffassung vertreten nämlich
das böse ist ein mangel am sein das böse
täuscht und das böse ist nur dass schein
gute das finde ich sehr spannend nach
thomas von aquin hängen wille um
vernunft eng miteinander zusammen die
vernunft ist auf das wahre gerichtet der
wille auf das gute wir brauchen beide
die vernunft muss den willen zeigen nach
wasser streben soll wenn die vernunft
sich jetzt dem willen nur das scheint
gute vorhand dann kann der wille böse
hanke als die böse handeln besteht in
der verfolgung eines schein guten hier
kommt der scheinen spiel und das ist
sicherlich ein wichtiges
charakteristikum des bösen
dann haben wir es
gehabt mit und leibnitz
war oben rechts den linken
leibnitz h die these vertreten dass wir
der besten aller möglichen welten leben
dann kann man sich natürlich fragen
woher kommt dann das gute warum darf in
der besten aller möglichen welten das
gute überhaupt existiert leibnitz
vertritt die these dass
gott das böse zu lassen musste selbst in
der besten aller möglichen welten
warum wegen dem mahl und metaphysik um
es mal um mittag risiko ist die
endlichkeit der geschöpfe also gott nach
leibnitz musste geschöpfe schaffen das
entspricht zahlung charakter seinen
guten charakter ab indem er jedem
geschütze wie uns menschen erschaffen
hat kam damit auch die endlichkeit und
wir sind ja endlich gewesen und werden
mehr güter das geht ja nicht und wind
aus dieser endlichkeit folgt dann und
letzte hinsicht auch das böse lebens
beschreibt das böse wie eine trägheit er
bringt das beispiel dass verschiedene
beladene kenne in einem strom sich
befinden der strom ist das guten und die
kähne je nachdem wie schwer sie beladen
sind die haben eine kraft der
widerständigkeit die widersetze sich
aufgrund ihrer trägheit
gegen das gute und diese kraft der
trägheit hat einerseits einen passiven
aspekt wir
verharren in der lage andererseits ist
die trägheit kraft aber auch eine kraft
als wir leisten widerstand dieser
spannung zwischen trägheit fraktion und
aktivität steht nach leidens das böse
zeitschrift pc
dann hatten mit immanuel kant zu tun wir
haben uns zunächst mit dem guten
beschäftigt ich mach oben rechts den
linken zu dieser zeit das gute ist nach
kannten oder gute wille
die handlung die aus dem guten willen
volk ist nach kant irrelevant die es
nicht entscheidend oder zumindest nicht
an erster stelle der wille ist wie ein
juwel zu verstehen und die handlung die
aus dem billen entspringen kann wie die
einfassung also die umgebung zb eine
brosche aus silber gold die sache
verglichen mit dem wert des juwels eher
nebensächlich
gut ist also nur ein guter wille kann
ist kein konsequenz ii all ist kant geht
es nicht um die konsequenz
die sie es wenn der börsen aus dann
mache ich auch oben rechts sind in
grants theorie des bösen böse kann man
analog sagen ist er leider und böser
wille also es geht um die maximen die
subjektiven handlungs grundsätze die
sind dann böse werden sie sich nicht
vernünftig allgemeiner lassen also kann
denkt moralität ganz da gibt es eine
vernünftige verallgemeinern barkeit er
geht aber noch weiter was das böse
anbelangt das böse hat immer was mit
unserem eigenen dunkel zu tun also im
bösen versuchen wir immer uns ausnahmen
zu erlauben gegenüber der strenge des
gesetzes wir können es nicht ertragen
nach kant mit dem gebot im absoluten
gebotes gerade dokusoaps folge zu
leisten wir wollen immer irgendwie eine
ausnahme unser land und diese ausnahme
die wir uns vernünftig die wir uns
zurecht legen darin besteht nach kann
das frühjahr
geht es weiter johann gottlieb fichte
wichtig nicht einerseits an kant an
andererseits aber auch an leibnitz
wichtig sagt das böse ist die kraft der
trägheit das ist leider auch da mach ich
oben rechts den link ein
doch ich das sagt und das böse
entstammt einer aktivität des menschen
die zurechenbar ist er selbst sich träge
zu machen
selbst nicht mehr dem gesetz folgen zu
wollen und das sittengesetz die
aufforderung des im gesetz in sich zu
verdunkeln
das ist so die tsg verdunkelt test der
verdunkeln des boot des gesetzes und
weil es uns nicht mehr klar vor augen
steht können wir dadurch gegen das
sittengesetz handeln wir können aber
nachrichten und das unterscheidet ihn
von augustinus nicht direkt gegen das
gebot des vierten gesetzes verstoßen wir
müssen das jetzt erst verdunkeln also
abschwächen und dann können wir dagegen
hand und böse
das ist leibniz wgl ist auch ein ganz
interessanter kandidat gewesen
egl betrachtet das gut und böse nicht so
sehr hasste perspektive des willens der
handlung ist aus der perspektive der
logik der begriffe also das gute das
böse verhalten sich so dass das böse
immer ein schein erzeugt das böse schein
haft verfasst um das böse immer nur
abstrakt also nicht konkret das böse
entzieht sich der wirklichkeit das böse
hat keinen bestand aber regelt sich das
ganze team aus logischer begrifflicher
in sicht das war eine sehr spannende sie
zu auch sehr kompliziert was sie gesagt
als entscheidend ist das gute und böse
ist auf die kluge der begriffe zu
beziehen und der schein spielt dabei
eine ganz ganz große rolle das böse
täuscht uns als das gute diese
möglichkeit nicht wir sind dann
übergegangen zu hannah arendt die art
den begriff der qualität geprägt gibt es
verschiedene auffassung die banalität zu
verstehen ist das böse wirklich banale
hier ging es um das beispiel von adolf
eichmann dem dazu nase tourismus eine
wichtige rolle gespielt hat bei der
judenvernichtung er hat die ganzen
transporte organisiert
sagt eichmann war ein gedankenloser
schreibtischtäter
der sich einfach nicht wirklich gedanken
um die konsequenzen machen konnte
das haben wir auch kritisch diskutiert
erreicht man wirklich banal oder hatte
nicht mehr sich den schreien der
banalität verliehen also hat er nur so
getan als ob ein einfacher
schreibtischtäter ein kleines rädchen im
getriebe
krisenzeit so wurde das war das ergebnis
unserer diskussion mehr sind daraus
möglichen banalität als scheindebatte
täter steht
für die passfahrt ein buch geschrieben
über die natur des guten und sie
vertritt eine neo aristotelische theorie
des guten das gute ist immer auf das
menschliche leben bezogen
der marginale school ist der der art des
menschen
und das böse muss analog es einen
natürlichen perfekt verstanden werden
sie bringt ihr als beispiel das beispiel
eines trittbrettfahren de wolfes also
wolf der nicht jagd der sie nicht mit
jagd der aber dennoch frist also der
letztendlich betrübt in der gesellschaft
aber denn irgendwie seine art nicht
entspricht das haben wir auch ein
bisschen kritisch diskutiert können wir
das böse wirklich analog zum natürlichen
defekt verstehen
oder muss da nicht noch mehr freiheit an
spezielle theorien des bösen
damit uns am beispiel von suse nehmen
einer amerikanischen philosophen und von
bettina stangneth mit ihrem buch böses
denken fast zu nehmen hat die anschläge
des nächsten september zum ausgangspunkt
genommen
in new york und hat die these vertreten
dass im modernen bösen die
unterscheidung zwischen dem natürlichen
übel und dem moralischen über immer mehr
verschwindet also die anschläge des 11
september die endeten so sagt sie
jedenfalls eine naturkatastrophe
als einem moralisch höchst einem
wesentlichen das war ein natur
schauspieler naturkatastrophe die
zelebriert wurde
bettina stangneth sagt dass dort auch
der titel an wir können auch selbst
durch unser denken böses bewirkt damit
grenzt sich von aller ahrens theorie ab
wonach bei
manz handlungen nur durch eine folge von
gedankenlosigkeit zu verstehen und ihn
erstattet sagt auch das denken selbst
kann böse sein die denkungsart die wir
haben die kann diesen handlung führen
aber mehr kann man wieder auf ideologien
eingehen wir haben darüber diskutiert
was ideologien sind
und bettina stark und hat sogar den
begriff des akademischen bösen geprägt
also dass selbst im akademischen bereich
böses denken kultiviert werden kann sie
geht hier ihr auf die ästhetisierung 1
ist sagt all sein denken was nur noch
sich um sich selbst dreht weil es
ästhetisch wird weil es schön ist weil
es gut klingt aber nicht mehr auf
wahrheit zunkel ausgerichtet ist das ist
das böse denken okay mache ich oben
rechts dann den link zu dieser sitzung
wahrheit ja das war eine kurze
darstellung der wichtigsten positionen
diesem semester ich bedanke mich
vielmals für die aufmerksamkeit und
wünsche allen schöne semesterferien